good morning everyone welcome to jail
car all right we have 10 members so
representative grass can sit in
for Senator chandley who's not here oh
I'm sorry excuse me you're being blocked
you are here okay and and Whitley if we
have a full a full team of senators
except for Senator Lang
okay so all right um represent of grassy
can sit in for Senator W for Senator
Lang who is not here
representative hacken Phillips can and
we have five house members
where I'm leaving what the heck you
on seven house members okay we have a
surplus so represent hacken Phillips
you're on
Deck
okay uh the minutes of the previous
meeting do we have a
motion second
any discussion or
corrections I believe so
yes there were several enthusiastic
people but she was one of
them I wouldn't go that far but and
any discussion or comments on the
minutes those in favor I
opposed all right the consent agenda
item K is is has been requested to come
off by representative Lon so we'll do
that do we have a motion on the rest of
the consent
agenda second okay Senator Enis and
representative Schmidt any uh comments
questions or
concerns all right seeing none the the
motion is to approve the consent agenda
those in favor I I
opposed okay thank
you on the regular
agenda we would like to postpone item
I which is the water Council it's their
request so do we have a motion to do so
he'll
move okay Senator representative Schmidt
and a senator
seconded okay
those in favor I I
opposed okay that one will be on the
January
agenda all
right Department of
Safety so this is proposal 20237 to the
watercraft safety rules um this was one
that had been postponed previously due
to um a number of comments the
department wanted to address on the
final proposal
they did submit a conditional approval
uh late Tuesday I started to review it
there were still some substantive
comments on it that the agency and I are
still working on through discussions um
but at this point in time due to it
being postponed and there's still being
some issues I would recommend the
committee make a preliminary objection
at this point and allow the agency to
address those issues in a preliminary
objection
response okay I'll move
that is there a second second okay
representative Lynn second um good
morning M Mr Hills I take it you are in
fact working on this yeah yes uh good
morning attorney Dave Hills for the
Department of Safety um I just wanted to
thank the committee for the um patience
that it has had so far with this
proposal I know that in the last couple
of Cycles um you know we've essentially
asked for more time we've uh had some
challenges with the amount of comments
but also some unavoidable absences uh in
a couple of the Personnel that have been
on this uh and we do appreciate the
extra time um as Rebecca said if the
committee were to give us a preliminary
objection we would be continuing to um
work on uh our response okay any
questions comments or
concerns seeing none those in favor of a
preliminary objection based on staff
comments I I opposed
okay thank you very
much right Board of
Nursing okay um these are licensing
requirement rules um the nursing 300s so
this proposal was postponed from the
last meeting to allow the agency to
address the legislative intent comments
and uh the unclear comments and a
revised amended conditional approval
request has been filed and you should
have that in front of you the first
comment is on page two of the
PDF at the last meeting we discussed at
length the um the language and the rule
specifically in the statute the statute
allows for three types of lure and um
that's by
endorsement alternate educa alternate
experience and um uh forget the other
one but anyway um so right now the rule
still says alternate education when it
should read alternate experience and I
spoke with Tina a couple of days ago and
this is a mistake and so um she plans on
asking as part of the conditional
approval request today to uh change that
there in that section and then also in
section e below and so um besides that
you'll also see a comment down towards
the lower left of the page that points
out a need for legislation to address
the fact that there's still fee
Authority in this particular board
statute and that's just an FYI and um
again on the fee Authority um there has
been an updated informational note that
we've been placing on the board's rules
you'll see that on the last page and the
reason for that update is um we sat down
with the oplc and um we took a look at
HB 518 and that is um currently in
process and that should deal with the
the issue around the fees so if it
should pass um we shouldn't be needing
to make that uh com any longer the
agency will be doing some rule making
and is looking at some of their rules as
well um the only other issue with the
proposal is that there are some
legislative intent comments because the
remaining sections of the rule have been
expired since March and um I think that
the committee kind of talked about it a
little bit last time but um there are
some fees associated with it so you may
you know thought I would mention it but
anyway those are the um issues with this
proposal
Al good morning Miss Kelly good morning
Tina Kelly office of professional lenser
and
certification um with regards to with
everything that Rebecca said we're going
to make the change from um education to
experience and with regards to the um
expired rules it's either that they're
smaller part of a larger section or
they're in statute and so they've only
been enforced with regards to what's in
statute um fees are all covered in oplc
and I believe that was before March that
opl's fees went into
effect no their their fee rule actually
went into effect in July so there was a
gap from March to
July
good morning executive director Lindsay
Courtney office of professional Li
Insurance certification I apologize I
wasn't prepared to address this issue
today um the Board of Nursing had a
series of emergency rules as well so I'd
have to go back and review to see
whether those rules um included uh fees
but I but I do agree with you that our
fees went into effect uh in May
May no the the that proposal was
52 I think that was in the PLC 10002s I
think they went into effect in July or
August I think it was July Rebecca
Ricard is saying she believes it's July
too but um you could be right in any in
any event um director Courtney I think
the simplest thing would be if
you
went through your emergency rules and
the statute and identified any fees that
were inappropriately charged absolutely
well do
representative thank
you any other issues with these
rules questions all right and um like I
said in the outset um the board will
need an an oral um uh change to the
rules um to change that comparable or
sorry the alternate education to read
alternate
experience okay do we have such a motion
I'll make that motion okay is there a
second I'll second okay representative
Lynn represent grota any discussion
comments
questions those in favor
I
opposed all right thank you very
much the next EX the next proposal is
2023 141 definitions of financial
assistance and medical
assistance this particular proposal did
uh have a CA filed with our office um
after the deadline we have had um our
comments goinging back to the agencies a
little late this time around due to some
illnesses and absences in our own office
um so we would be in favor of the the
committee granting them a waiver um due
to the late CA and in that uh
conditional approval they did address
two of the issues um the first is on
page 14 of the conditional approval they
did change the citation from the federal
regulated uh Federal Regulation
definition of dependent child and cited
the statute um however I still had u a
little bit of uh
comment on that due to them saying it
was a definition and even though the
statutory title of that section says
definitions when you read it it's not
actually a definition it's more of a
description of what a needy child is in
order to be eligible for the financial
aid so I just in my comment um proposed
some language to just change that to say
um dependent child means as described uh
excuse me um a needy child means excuse
me I'm not feeling great I apologize uh
a dependent child means a needy child as
described in
RSA
1676 Section 5 um as opposed to what's
written which could be addressed in an
oral uh amendment to their conditional
approval if they agree and then the only
other comment is on page 20 of the
conditional approval text um where the
agency is not using the definition
statutory definition of specified
relative however in talking with the
agency this was an intentional Choice as
it seems that this state statute is
being amended to include court appointed
Guardians that's a change I believe will
take effect in early this upcoming year
and due to these being um Medicaid rules
that is not something that the Federal
Regulations allow um court appointed
Guardians is more for the purpose of
tanif assistance as opposed to Medicaid
so they are intentionally not adopting
the state statutory definition for that
reason um and those were the only two
comments I had on the conditional
approval uh good morning Nicole Valena
rules coordinator for
uh the rules unit for Department of
Health and Human
Services good morning David shney uh
Deputy Medicaid director uh with respect
to the definition for dependent
dependent child um attorney rard could
we just keep it I agree with saying as I
can't see you but as described in can we
just keep it as a dependent child and
not add the
needy um just to make sure I'm clear so
it's uh dependent child means a child
and then as described in I I would say
that would also be fine so we will make
that
change and then um with regards to
specified relative I think it's you know
if any members of the committee have
additional questions um after what
attorney rard I have a a question what
does this mean that a guardian of a
dependent child who is on Medicaid is
not themselves eligible for
Medicaid or is there some other
something else going on that I don't
quite
understand hi good morning um my name is
Don Tierney of the Medicaid policy
administrator for the Department of
Health and Human Services
and that's not what it means
means thank you what does it mean um it
just means
that I don't want to oversimplify it
very complicated but it would it would
mean um that the non-relative legal
guardian if that status permits them to
claim them on their taxes that the
income of the Guardian would then count
towards the child's eligibility where if
we don't include that
definition the guard
um their income will not count towards
the child's eligibility so if the the
potential is that the child would maybe
lose Medicaid Eligibility versus keeping
it or on the other
hand the
guardian may be in a parent caretaker
relative eligibility category which we
only get a 50/50 match for whereas now
they could be in their own household and
be eligible potentially under granted
advantage and we would get a higher
Federal match at the 9010
rate so we didn't really have a lot of
time also to analyze this by the time
the statute took effect to determine
whether or not it would be Bene more
beneficial for the child or the court
appointed
Guardian
Schmid how soon are you going to know
the answer to that
um probably not until after this takes
effect because we don't know really how
many people we're talking about that's
the other question I had yeah I don't
know okay
so you're trying to maintain the current
state status for court cour appointed
Guardians and not include them in the
general definition of yes responsible
adult for for child on Medicaid yes
until you figure out whether they ought
to be there or not yes and whether what
the cost could potentially be to the
department and to the
state okay and as I recall when we
changed it to allow the Guardians to get
tanif we didn't discuss the issue of
whether they were already eligible for
Medicaid or would be eligible for
Medicaid so there's no
clear
um legislative intent at least as far as
I remember does anybody have any more
information okay we don't none of us
have any better information so
um if we have any have a motion I'd like
to have you consider this and report
back back when you have a chance because
it's obviously something that was left
hanging when we changed the the uh the
guardian
rules representative Mor oh excuse me
director excuse me uh because we
have a late filed conditional approval
request and there's an oral adjustment
the committee would have to vote to
accept that separate from voting on The
Proposal
okay do we have such a
motion so mooves
second okay and representative brassy
your's back on deck and discussion
comments those in favor I opposed okay
so now we can consider
the the rule is there a motion on it
move to approve as edited
second that is including the verbal
correction and the action to report back
on
Guardians comments or
questions those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
and I'd love to find out what happens
with
those all
right all right um 2023 193 on Hospice
Services um the rules have been expired
since 2018 and 2022
all
right uh good morning uh Nicole
valenzula again for the record uh rules
coordinator for Department of Health and
Human Services um attorney munis before
we are we able to we made the other
editorial Corrections for you as well
with the um conditional approval request
was that that's correct that's all said
that's what we're talking about the the
conditional approval yes okay I wasn't
sure if we needed to go over those
details first or anything
okay expired rules
yes um it sounds like in speaking to the
program area there was some staff change
over around the time of when this rule
is expiring uh it was missed as soon as
we caught it we began regular Ru making
um at that
time um how could
you deal with Hospice Services which I
can imagine are pretty substantial
without having a rule in
place so under the New Hampshire statute
um it directed the department to file a
state plan amendment to cover Hospice
Services um up to the extent that
Medicare covers them so we've been um
following the Medicare regulations with
respect to Hospice Services um and the
regulations really apply to the fee for
service population which is only about
one and a half% of the Medicaid
population most of the um population is
in Managed Care um and so the Hospice
Services are delivered through the manag
care organizations which the state
contracts with um in accordance with uh
their program
manuals
gr so for those people who required the
services that were not
not on Medicare how was that handled so
the the Medicaid uh rules follow the the
Medicare rules so the
the when operating the program um we we
operated it consistent with the the
Medicare conditions for coverage and the
Medicare Federal
Regulations um so uh that's that's how
they were the the individual didn't need
to be Medicare eligible as long as they
had Medicaid and they were in Fe for
service uh we operated the program in
accordance with the the Medicare
regulations which is what we were
directed to do underneath the New
Hampshire
statute so so you were using the
existing Medicare rules for people who
are not eligible for
Medicare but they're eligible for
Medicaid um which is the coverage
benefit yes thank
you please so for those people people
let's pretend like me who are not on
Medicaid and not
Medicare how are those Services
administered uh they're administered
through the the Medicare program um
which is run through the federal
government if you're not on Medicare and
you're not on Medicaid your own
insurance presumably would deal with
hospice okay that's what I'm looking for
cover threee commercial plan yes the
market okay thank you that's helpful all
right any enforcement action during the
expiration of these rules that were P
penalized uh Hospice Care
Services was anybody penalized at all uh
absent any any if if they had if we had
these rules that violated the state
rules was there any enforcement action
at
all I don't know I'd have to take it
back uh full disclosure I started in
August so I don't have the the full
benefit of history since 2018 I don't
know if Don knows but I can I can take
it back and follow
up you might I don't know who who would
be responsible for doing this but it
sounds to me we have a real mess here
with multiple sets of
rules
and I find that it's going to be very
difficult for people to know which rule
applies and I how can we straighten that
out director moral do you have an
idea uh absent of legislative change I
do not know okay so it's in our court
then I think so thank
you move to approve the conditional
request
second any discussion questions
comments those in favor I opposed
okay thank you very
much good
luck all right so the next one is
196 uh determination of the assistant
payment and that one has been expired
since
2022 that's the only issue with
it uh good morning again uh Nicole
Valena administrative rules unit
Department of Health and Human Services
um with respect to this rule to be
completely honest this is um an example
of when a program or an agency used to
be allowed to open up one single
paragraph and make an edit and so
therefore the section had sort of
multiple different expiration dates and
so this is an example of how part of the
section was missed due to part of it not
being expired and part of it being
expired so we happy that that's no
longer an option but that's the truth of
how this one was
missed and within that section honestly
it's actually this rule is the bulk of
it is just about how determining
assistance payments and the timeline so
the bulk of the rule is discussing sort
of at what time a payment is made Etc
and it's only
addressing again this specific
population um of folks receiving
assistants
who say they may be living with a
grandparent or something and then they
don't have a shelter cost and so they
have a one-third reduction of assistance
so the bulk of the rule is just talking
about what days of the month you might
be um administering payment
Etc sen just so I'm clear so again you
had one paragraph out of an entire rule
that expired and this now brings the
whole rule into we have a single single
rule not paragraphs out that have
outliers opposite we H we had one
paragraph that wasn't expired with the
other paragraphs expired but that last
paragraph had to be the one not expired
thank you so it move to conditionally
approve
second any uh comments questions
discussion those in favor I
opposed right thank you right
ambulances um so this one is actually an
interim rule um the the agency filed
this interim rule because the effective
rule expired on December 1st um of this
year they did file this rule prior to
that expiration but unlike in regular Ru
making the filing of an interm rule will
not stay that expiration date um but
that's why part e of RSA 541
a191 allows agencies to file interm
rules to limit the amount of time a rule
is expired before regular rule making
can occur um the agency had originally
filed the rule as it was effective um
because this rule had not been in rle
making since 2013 it was a little bit um
outside of our current manual standards
um so they did file a conditional
approval to address um the lack of
certification that was uh needed to be
in the rule text and also to update what
one of the form names so the only
comment I had is that the current rule
is is now technically expired and has
been since the first of this
month good morning good morning Allison
radme the administrator for the
administrative rules unit of the
Department of Health and Human
Services good morning Don Tierney
administrative policy for the um sorry
for the Department of Health and Human
Services with respect to the um the
expert of the rule immediately upon uh
realizing this was to expire on December
1st uh we knew we couldn't file regular
rule making uh and get the notice uh in
to OLS on time uh so we did immediately
put this into an interm Rule and we are
prepared to move forward uh after the
holiday um probably the first week in
January to start this going into regular
Ru
making
okay move to conditionally
approve
I'd like to ask if there were any
enforcement
issues none okay
good uh are there is there a policy in
HHS to examine your rules for expired
rules because I was very uh shocked that
you had so many expired rules showing up
this month we're trying our best um
there's two of us in the unit and
there's 3,000 rules about in the
department um so as we have a new
program that we're kind of trying to
work with uh we don't love it too much
but we're also on our own as uh we are
certifying rules uh we're actually
updating our own spreadsheets so we can
kind
of try to let programs know um but again
there's two of us in about 3,000 rules
so okay well that's a that's an we're
trying our best that's why you seeing so
many kind of come forward because we're
trying to identify them okay thank you
you any other questions or comments just
a comment on our our side of the things
we are trying to incorporate um
basically a a a a warning for when the
rules will be expiring that that will be
a new thing coming when with our new
system as it comes up just maybe a few
months okay well that that will help
because private spreadsheets are
notorious for missing
things all right any uh we have a motion
yes okay any further comments
questions seeing none those in favor I I
opposed all right thank you very much
and good
luck so next item is 2023 152 The
Establishment and operation of area
agencies uh this one also had a
conditional approval request filed that
addressed almost all of uh the comments
that was on the final proposal the only
remaining comment and it seems to be
maybe just an unintentional error on
page six of the uh request conditional
approval request text they had changed
one term in which I had commented on
they were using the term developmental
disability service system which was not
a defined term the statute had defined
Service delivery system
and in that particular section they
changed the first mention of it but the
second me mention of it they left it as
the developmental disab uh disability
service system which could be addressed
if the agency made an oral amendment to
their conditional approval request and
then that would address all of the
issues in this
proposal okay good morning uh again for
the record Allison radme the
administrator of the administrative
rules rules unit for the Department of
Health and Human Services
um good morning attorney Melissa nth
with the Department of Health and Human
Services this was an oversight on our
part uh when we were making that initial
uh wording change to uh sub paragraph 8
uh so we do um agree with the change um
in 8B uh to change developmental
disability service system to Service
delivery system uh to mirror what the
language about
okay that will move to approve the oral
change to the conditional approval
second any further questions comments
concerns those in favor I opposed all
right thank you very much move to
approve as
edited um we have to adopt the oral
first if we did it like last time oh the
uh and so now we now we're back on the
rule itself as edited move to approve
back in
any
comments those in favor I opposed all
right thank you very much that's that
one Board of mental health practice
chairwoman Maguire did you want to take
up the item that was moved from consent
it's also an HHS
proposal uh yes well we've got them up
there that would help that's item K
which is number
243 the impaired driver programs
representative Leon took this off
consent so
uh to um this was on the impaired driver
um programs and I think we um we did
some back and forth with the agency and
uh they filed a conditional approval
request and I think I only had a couple
of editorial comments left on it which
they could handle you know uh in a
response but um I wasn't sure if there
was anything else that um that we needed
to address I don't think I had any
informational notes on this one either
okay representative Leon if you would
express your concern um thank you um as
I was reading through um I know that
these programs have been operating
through video conferencing so that's a
virtual face Toof face but not an
in-person face Toof face I just wanted
to make sure that the rules assuming
that that's something that was an
intention for the Department to continue
that the rules specify that face Toof
face includes a virtual face Toof face
and not just inperson face to
face good morning again for the record
Allison radney administrator of the
administrative rules unit for the
Department of Health and Human
Services and I'm Jenny O Higgins a
senior policy analyst for Behavioral
Health with
DHHS um I have spoken with the program
uh prior to coming up here and we have
uh agreed to add a new new definition of
face to face uh so this would be a new
paragraph p and we would remember the
remaining uh definitions um and what we
have is means in person or via an online
platform in real time when all
participants can see each other
clearly that would work for me thank you
okay thank you so we would need to have
a conditional approval uh motion so
moved
second all right any further discussion
comments
concerns okay all in favor I
opposed all right and and you'll submit
that in writing to the ol thank you okay
that's
good all
right and I believe there was public
testimony too sorry oh okay um you're
right public estimon before we leave
let's make sure we haven't object done
something you would object object to
Maran
Kelly I'm sorry about that we're
uh please turn your mic
on push the button
push there you go how's that beautiful
Marian Kelly assistant director amethyst
Foundation
um I would specifically I've had to
write this down and I'll keep it brief
I'd like to specifically address the fee
increases pursuant to ha50
501 when RSA 265a was signed into law
effective January 1st 2013 the statute
significantly revised delivery of
services an unintentional consequence of
the law has been a reduction in idcmp
revenues that has led directly to the
closures of several idcm programs
throughout the state I counted six this
morning just off the top of my head
amethyst Foundation has been
Incorporated for 41 years and is such we
are well acquainted with the business
Acumen needed to run a successful
nonprofit since
2013 amethyst has managed to stay
solvent by the following measures we've
tightened up expenditure across the
board we are not doing Capital
Improvements we're temporarly closing
offices and we're not filling positions
as they become vacant after several
years of Warning by our Auditors it has
become apparent amethyst can no longer
continue to serve the population in need
of DWI programs with without the
proposed fee increases you may or may
not be aware that's the only source of
revenue for the ID cmps its fee per
service um many of the um as some of you
may know the idcmp is meant monthly over
the course of six months to assess the
rule changes and specifically in this
case to look at fee increases we were
very very careful we wanted to represent
um the cost of living adjustments and we
were really careful balancing the needs
of the clients with the abil ability of
the idcm PS to continue to offer idcm
DWI services so I'm just urging you to
accept and confirm the proposed fee
increases you do not want to see DWI
programs not be able to operate because
of the reduction in fees that the RSA
unfortunately allowed all right thank
you very much any questions um well I
have a question I'm looking at the
schedule of fees it comments that the
emergency rule expired in April
how on
Earth how on Earth have we been running
the programs for the last eight
months are you asking me I'm I'm asking
anyone who knows are you do you know no
we're we've been very aware that the
rules expired and very um concerned
about it but um Nicole would
know are you set with me thank
you I'm sorry can I just ask one
question before you run away so you're
you were talking about the fees that are
defined in this fee schedule you feel
need to be increased in order to allow
the program remain viable rules the
rules show the increases that we felt
were fair to clients programs the rules
that were adop that we already adopted
you're okay with yes thank you okay
thank you okay thank you I have a
question so the document you were
reading from we have
that document you were reading from we
have that in our uh it was not submitted
to the office uh prior to this meeting
um if you wanted to forward it to our
office we could disseminate it to the
the document of that you were just
reading from your statement okay I will
thank
you it will be part of the transcript
too thank
you good morning Allison radme
administrator for the administrative
rules unit of the Department of Health
and Human Services M that's a mouthful
when you're saying it like five
times so I did want to clarify uh haa
50501 where H which houses the schedule
of fees that was not expired um that was
not expired the emergency rule that we
put forward was um only dealing with the
the credit card transaction fees that
are provided um or charged by Banks
allowing uh the programs I believe to to
collect those fees from their clients um
so they wouldn't be losing money um we
originally were we were trying real hard
to get this rule through um but we
wanted to prevent expiration so we did a
lot of stakeholder uh work on the back
end which kind of required us to push it
off um coming to Jael car but it was
very minor uh a very minor rule change
that was expired it was not the entire
free
schedule thank you that's and and the
rule that specifically expired again is
if they had a $100 fee and it was a $5
credit card charge they could charge
$105 rather than the flat $100 they
would be able to recover the the banking
cost basically exactly we didn't want
them to be out because essentially they
were losing Revenue because they were
paying that cost of those fees yeah and
the existing rules other than that one
piece were not expired we not expired
not expired and even if they were they
would have continued because you were in
Ru making at the time correct correct
yeah
I'm looking at the emergency Rule and
that's correct it was just for that one
piece so it had a paragraph that just um
had the transaction fee um for every
payment made um uh the transaction fee
so that was all that was was put into
place with the emergency Rule and so
when the emergency rule expired the rule
just um went back into effect as it was
all right thank you very much I'm
relieved thank you all right any other
issues okay thank you very
much the board of mental health
practice yeah um so there are uh just
three issues that are keeping uh this
item from being on consent there has
been a conditional approval request
filed um but first is uh that there are
a couple of places in the rule that the
board um that the rule says board rather
than oplc and so Tina planned on um
orally requesting for that change and
that's an a couple places on pages three
and seven of the conditional approval
packet um the second reason is there was
some difference between the fees on the
board's website and what's in the PLC
rule but Tina and I walk through those
um each one of those uh fees and uh
that's due to the program Health facil
that program fee rather and so um
there's no issue there um lastly there's
been some testimony submitted from the
community Behavioral Health
Association and um that is linked on the
website as well as an email um exchange
from Tina um talking about uh that
testimony so the the testimony says that
it's not possible to complete the
required supervisory experience within 4
years and uh that amount of time that
has to be um done is is 100 hours um the
board says that the requirement has to
be met within four not not 2 years and
uh the rules don't cap the number of
hours per week that a supervisory
experience um you know that number that
amount that they can do for each week I
took a look at the rule and and I think
that's correct it doesn't talk about a
maximum amount it talks about a minimum
which is um roughly about an hour a week
and um so I don't think that the rules
been read correctly around that piece of
it um so you know that's roughly like I
said about 1 hour a week so about 54
hours a year so they could meet2 hours a
year right sorry 5 hours a year right so
is is that one hour a week a minimum or
a maximum that is a minimum so they
could do more and they it's doable
within two years but they do have four 4
years they can renew it and have up to
four years um there was a comment that
um there wasn't a limit on it before
it's only so that somebody doesn't go
forever so four years is completely
doable and the other part of this is
that the certification is not required
from what I understand and it is simply
for reimbursement purposes uh let's
let's see is everyone happy with the
supervisory being four no more than four
years any issues with
that okay so is that what the rule
states yeah that's the way I read the
rule okay so we'll try and make it more
obvious if there's confusion but you
right four years seems like more than
enough time to get to suffer through
that okay so moving on to the next
issue what's
certification um thank you madam chair
members of the committee Lindsay
Courtney executive director oplc so this
certification came back um came about I
believe in the 2019 legislative session
um historically the way Mental Health
Providers have obtained their license is
they graduate they have to get a period
of supervised
experience um they had to submit a an
agreement to the board it was a
candidate agreement that was approved by
the board but it wasn't a license and
they were able to essentially practice
under supervision and then at some point
they apply for a license but during that
period of time they're not able to be
eligible for reimbursement because
they're not actually licensed so during
I believe it was 2019 or
2020 um the
statute was changed to allow for
lure um but the portion of the statute
regarding candidates has not yet been
repealed the way I interpret that is
that it's essentially an optional
pathway for those who want a license um
while they obtain their
supervision and the license allows them
to do what be reimbursed for services
it's a reimbursement issue as opposed to
authorization to perform the services
issue again if I please so again this is
an insurance issue really right so the
ability for without a license they
cannot get reimbursed from an insurance
carrier but with a license they can get
reimbursed from an insurance carrier for
services provided right but the statute
didn't eliminate the option to to do it
without the
license okay so they are working under
supervision but this allows them to be
paid for the work they're doing under
supervision correct okay that doesn't
appear to be the understanding of the
people that wrote us that letter and
submitted the
testimony so we'll try and obviously
communication chair
yes can you explain then the
um the reason for this misunderstanding
because this was not addressed by the
board during the
hearings so correct this issue didn't
come up before the board the issue that
came up before the board was the two
years and the minimum 100 I guess the
point that I was trying to make is that
if the concern is that you can't
complete within four years 100 hours it
doesn't mean that you would never
qualify to get your license um as a
clinical mental health counselor it just
means that you would do it and not be
eligible for reimbursement because the
statutory Authority for the candidate
agreement process is still in statute I
will say there's a proposed piece of
legislation that would repeal that um
but for right now there there Remains
Two
Pathways so we really so far excuse me
follow up please follow
up we're really only addressing right
now the first first letter because we
have two two areas of concern from the
right and and it when I read the letter
it's it's implied that the certification
was not for counseling it was for other
duties so
that's it sounds like there's a major
miscommunication followup follow please
but these this this letter was presented
to the board before the hearing so they
knew about it and they didn't address it
then or they didn't so I just don't know
why that would happen I do think and I'm
not going to speak for the board because
uh I represent an entirely different
entity but I do believe that they did
address it it's set forth in the final
proposal um the issue regarding whether
100 hours is or I'm sorry one hour per
week is a maximum versus a minimum as
well as the renewal time frame that was
addressed the board just believed that 4
hours um was a sufficient period of time
time in order to complete your
supervision okay but what about their
concern about the duties allowable with
that
certification is that
a a real issue or just being conf
confused I'm not sure about that I
didn't about
this I will say that the board addressed
everything that was in the letter
and they did go through it step by
step on that particular issue I can't I
don't know exactly what their reasoning
was so I can't I can't address that at
this time all
right yeah I can't speak to the co scope
of practice issue we did um send the
letter to the board yesterday um and
requested that somebody be able to
attend they weren't able to attend um
and I can't speak to the scope of
practice issue that's entirely under the
purview of the board okay but your
understanding is that this certificate
is for someone who is working under
supervision and the supervision
agreement has been approved by the board
correct okay
so thank you any other comments
questions
concerns move to
approve comments those in favor
IES excuse me there's so many to me it's
still not
clear um I'm just wondering if we can
postpone this for the next meeting do we
have time to do that we do our deadline
is uh before is after the next
meeting director M but we do have a
motion uh to approve pardon
sorry
what's that if there's consensus to push
off I can move to
reconsider I think that would be
appropriate yes
second okay we have a motion to
reconsider our
vote those in favor I I opposed
I okay um and then there is a motion to
postpone the final approval until our
January meeting with the hope that the
board will be able to address some of
these issues by then with that uh is
that the int the the intent no okay so
we have a motion to
postpone okay those in favor I
opposed all right we will see you in
January with a report from the board and
hopefully all our other issues have been
resolved
okay anything else director
moral we have two items under other
business the first is an uh emergency
rule from oplc it was filed a week
ago um this summer I think it was in
July oplc adopted uh PLC
1002 a lengthy proposal I believe uh due
to a number of statutory changes
um as part of it um the licensure period
uh or the period for certificate of
Authority for Architects and
Professional Engineers changed from 12
months to 24 months at the same time the
fee doubled uh which appeared logical
and no comment was made either from us
or the public uh it turns out in
retrospect that that was not the intent
of
oplc uh that they intended to keep the
fee the same and they are concerned
about uh there will be costs to the
engineers and The
Architects um I mean there does seem to
be an emergency it's in essence created
by the
agency
uh through oversight apparently um and
there was a discussion of the number of
people uh close to 1900 between the two
uh
boards um and they're talking about uh
close to
$350,000 but I'm not sure of this of
that sum because that would I assume be
for the 24mon period I mean if they
start rule making immediately within
three or four months they could have the
regular rule finished and uh so I don't
know what the actual amount would be uh
I don't know when
whether these people uh lienes are all
licensed at the same time whether it's
staggered by birth month or what but
perhaps the agency can
answer thank you Lindy Courtney oplc
executive director so um attorney moral
is absolutely correct in this past
summer we had attempted to take all of
the boards existing fees and put them
into one proposal which uh was approved
in PLC 10002s there were a couple of
changes in statute to the statutory term
some went from three years to two years
and some went from one year to two years
so the intent was to take the existing
fee and double it to account for the
two-year time frame what we actually did
uh with respect to the coas was
quadruple the fee um and so instead of
it being um so originally one of the
fees was
$77.50 for one year instead of it being
$155 we um set the fee at
$310 I think that was just due to
drafting errors in multiple revisions
and not understanding if we had already
made the calculation or not we did not
receive any comments from the boards we
did not receive any comments from the
public until about two weeks ago we
received a comment and then we reviewed
the matter and realized that that was
not the intent and and and I I think
it's the right uh thing to do um so we
filed the emergency rules and we're
working on refunding the people who have
already paid for
renewals so the uh engineering and
architecture licenses go out over the
course of the Year yes
correct all right any other discussion
on this this issue this rule all right
well thank you for catching up and thank
you for doing the right thing thank you
right all
right the remaining item is uh the
schedule of Del car meetings for next
year I think you each have a copy uh the
regular meetings are as normal which
would be
um which would be the uh third
Friday of the month during the first six
months of the year uh because of session
in the second six months they would be
on Thursdays to avoid having you come in
during the summer on a
Friday the continued meetings are always
subject to change uh legislative
schedule may change uh we've tried to
avoid holidays but certainly those can
be changed on an ongoing
basis okay and and we would need a
motion and to move to approve the dates
can okay move by Senator second by
representative Schmid any discussion on
these we did check and none of them are
on Easter which
is the most important floating holiday
in the
spring okay any discussion those in
favor I
opposed
okay
be back on January
19th yes I assuming that we're not
having a continued meeting I don't see
any need for one do you does anybody
okay we will cancel the continued
meeting and uh meet come back on the
19th anything else all right in that
case we are adjourned thank you all you
happy holidays to you all yeah happy
holidays
okay